- My wish is for you to help
a strong sustainable movement
to educate every child about food.
To inspire families to cook again
and to empower people
everywhere to fight obesity.
I came here to start a food revolution
that I profoundly believe in.
- They had a big idea to change the world,
but they couldn't do it alone.
- So, my wish-
- For my wish-
- My wish-
- So, my wish-
- And now, here's my wish.
Food is simple, it's just raw ingredients,
but it's the most powerful
killer on the planet.
Every child has the human
right to be taught about food,
where it comes from, how
it affects their body,
and they should be shown at school
because it's at the frontline
of the fight against obesity.
What happens at Charlton Manor
is that incredible head teacher
took it to the next level.
- In the past, the children
weren't eating the right things.
I've been inspired by Jamie
to educate the school about the fact that
we're feeding the children the wrong food.
And I thought, well, the timetable
is an already crowded place.
There is so many lessons
in the primary curriculum,
how can you introduce another subject
for teachers to teach?
So we looked at English,
we looked at math, science,
history, geography,
and we saw how we could
put that around food.
- When you incorporate cooking,
it's something everyone looks forward to.
- Today we're doing a little
bit of science in the kitchen.
- We are going to combine
our lessons on Diwali,
but also our lessons
on shape and symmetry.
- Would you say this is a physical change
or a chemical change that I'm making?
- Physical.
- Physical change, you're right.
- For history topics, we talk about
the whole history of chocolate,
and so we can do the
whole topic around that.
- Okay, and the Aztecs have
been cooking with chocolate.
- And it's interesting because
it's not made as they think
with all the milk in
that they would have had,
and the taste is very, very different.
Some children like it,
some children don't.
For maths, simple weighing and measuring.
- We're gonna be doing a lot of measuring,
‘cause we have to measure out some liquids,
which we did last term,
we did some measuring.
- What he's done is he's put food
at the heart of the school,
and he's fed the stomach and the mind.
- Charlton Manor is a state school,
about 80 percent of children come from
areas that are identified as in poverty.
The children had very little experience
of being outside in the countryside,
knowing about food growing.
Over a period of time, we're
able to build a garden.
- Welcome to the secret garden.
- This is our greenhouse.
This is our compost bin.
This is our warmery.
This is our vegetable patch.
And these are our chickens.
- The chickens come out,
and they try and chase ya.
- I had to run for my life.
- Up at the community garden, we've got
two poly tunnels, so we
can grow year round.
- I will pick onions, broccoli and carrots
because they're all healthy
and make you stronger, obviously,
and they just make me happy, so yeah.
- Twelve or 13 years ago
there was a reluctance
to engage in this sort of curriculum.
There were many people that couldn't see
what we were aiming for and
what we were trying to do.
Obesity hadn't reached the
epidemic proportions
that it's reached now.
We're getting children that
look and appear more healthy.
Concentration is so much higher.
Behavior issues are incredibly lower
than they have been in the past.
- One of the great things they've done
is introduce us to worlds of healthy food.
- Before I was a really picky eater.
I feel better when I eat healthier food.
- You fail your maths A level,
that's not gonna shorten
your life by 10 years.
- You don't die young 'cause you didn't do
your geography homework.
These kids die young if they don't know
how to feed themselves.
I think Tim and the team would inspire
head teachers across
the world, and parents.
Any teacher has the same capacity
to be as brilliant as he is.
His story we want to replicate,
but the truth is we've
got so much more to do.
- Jamie really revolutionized
our school dinners
and it really has hugely
impacted on all of the children,
but so many in a deep way
which is gonna stick with them
for the rest of their lives.
When you change a life like that,
it makes it all worthwhile.
From all of us at Charlton
Manor, thank you, Jamie.
- Thank you, Jamie.